ici sur le site de la découverte du
premier puis le dieu cameron qui est
juste à la gauche ici alors c'est sur le
site on a découvert l'huile le 13
février 2009
ça fait depuis les années 20 30 40 qui
faisait de la recherche sont manitoba la
saskatchewan l'alberta millions us en
prendre 3 puis nous étaient chers qu'à
ça sert alors il y avait un des six vins
qui vient quelques millions
il n'y avait probablement pas de
francophones qui ont travaillé sur les
premiers rires
les gens étaient probablement dans
majorité dans le coin ici c'était des
gens de descendance ukrainienne et aussi
des anglais qui sont venus avec avec les
plus hauts à sailly un impact sur tous
le comté de le dire est qu en
particulier celles ci sur leur terrain
pour eux ils ont travaillé avec les
compagnies duels et on partenariat
enlever la construction de routes et
tous ars a causé dans le développement
de sa région
non